I'm in India in Mumbai what used to be
called Bombay and behind me is the
famous Taj Mahal Hotel and when I'm in
India of course I begin to think about
Indian chemistry Indian science and
they're really two things which come to
my mind not necessarily the most
important but the ones that really
strike me one is a tragedy and the
others a triumph
so let's begin with the tragedy which
was the worst chemical accident that
ever occurred and it happened the city
of Bhopal which is a long way from here
right in the middle of India and it was
due to a discharge of chemicals from a
closed chemical factory
it wasn't even making chemicals used to
make insecticide but they decided to
close it down and in this factory which
was being decommissioned there was a
tank of a particular chemical known as
methyl isocyanate isocyanate is a group
which contains nitrogen carbon and
oxygen in a line NC o-- and methyl
isocyanate can react with water to
generate heat and to generate gases and
you can imagine the heat plus gas
generates pressure and the tank can blow
up and what is worse that one of the
gases it can generate is hydrogen
cyanide which is very poisonous and if
you breathe it can kill you it really
quite a low dose so imagine it in the
middle of the night this reaction took
place and while it was dark clouded the
tank burst and clouds of poison gas
spread across the town across the
poorest areas of the town killing
thousands of people there's still
argument whether it was two and a half
thousand or fifteen thousand people but
an enormous number and injuring a lot
more there are several theories how the
water got in the tank ranging from
straightforward misfortune to bad
management of the plants or even
sabotage and there's even not quite
clear exactly what reaction took place
because the products of the reaction
depends on the temperature so the
proportion of hydrogen cyanide depends
on exactly what temperature the tank
broke hydrogen cyanide is very powerful
poison because the cyanide group can
bind to various molecules in the body
one of these symptoms is that your lips
we go blue fortunately I never seen
anybody has died from cyanide poison but
it's a very painful death and very quick
so if you're asleep and breathe hydrogen
cyanide you would be dead before you
knew it it was a terrible tragedy but it
was a wake-up call to the chemical
industry across the world so the
suffering of these poor people was not
in vain because nowadays chemical plants
are operated far more safely than they
were thirty years ago
India is also very famous for one
particular physicist professor Rama and
professor Raman worked in Kolkata now
called Kolkata in Bengal and the right
very East of India and he was professor
of physics at the University there and
he discovered in effect which to this
day is called the Raman effect and for
which he won the Nobel Prize for Physics
in 1930 and the Raman effect is the
basis of a very important sort of
spectroscopy that is now used all over
the world it's really quite simple and
it's a technique which is now applied to
all sorts of chemical reactions and
chemical processes and it involves
shining a beam of light which is of a
single colour blue or green or red and
shining it onto a sample and the sample
scatters the light so a large amount of
the red light or blue light is scattered
back and you can see it but if you
analyze light very carefully you also
find that there is a small proportion of
the light has had its color changed at
very discrete frequencies the correspond
to the vibrations of the molecule on the
substance you are radiating and it is
these frequencies that give you a
signature of the molecule sort of
fingerprint of the molecule and allows
you to tell what it is
when Raman did it
his first experiments he did them here
in India where the sunshine is very
bright except now in the monsoon season
and this intense light was enough from
the sunlight to do the experiment when I
was a student you had to use huge
mercury lamps to get a Raman spectrum
and it took several hours but after the
invention of lasers then you could use a
laser and record the Raman spectrum in a
few seconds or even less so Raman
spectroscopy has become enormous ly
important you can use it for identifying
the pigments the paint's that are used
in fine art you can tell if something is
a forgery you can use it for monitoring
chemical processes to tell if things are
going wrong and so it is a fantastic
discovery that is a credit to India and
which is remembered by chemists all over
the world